foreign
ER and that you're all alone
yeah come on Chad open up
it's Santa Claus
and his elf
We're not gonna hurt you no no
that's a nice presents for you
be a good little fella now and open the
door
hello everyone and welcome to a new
episode of RT Essentials I'm Mark Ellis
today we're diving into the world of
classic family movies ones that not only
bring the whole family together but they
are certified Classics in their own
right as well and we don't just toss
around the word classic all willy-nilly
these are films that are Timeless
re-watchable and important parts of film
history and or popular culture our
buffer for the films goes up to the
2000s because let's be honest Classic
Movies need to simmer and in an attempt
to save a few breaths along the way some
of these movies go in the way back
machine they're all certified fresh and
we're pretty much all selected for the
national film registry by the Library of
Congress okay our list of all time
family movies starts right now The
Wizard of Oz and as for you my fine
Mighty this is true I can't attend you
here and now as I like but just try to
stay out of my way just try I'll get you
my pretty and your little dog too
and clicking its heel together three
times to get this list started is 1939
The Wizard of Oz this is an adaptation
of L frank Baum's Children's Fantasy
novel The Wonderful Wizard of Oz first
published in 1900. the film stars Judy
Garland is Young Dorothy Gale who along
with her trusty dog Toto is carried away
by a tornado from her Kansas farm to the
magical land of Oz there she embarks on
a journey with three new friends to find
the wizard who can get her back home a
role that had a few candidates including
the biggest child star of all time
Shirley Temple and newcomer Deanna
Durbin one of the best known singers of
the era along with the cast the film
generated plenty of Interest due to its
use of Technic color which caused many
filmmakers to spend way too much time
trying to find just the right shade of
yellow for that famous brick road but
for that we should all pay them homage
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
that led to an Academy Award nomination
for best art direction to go with
nominations for Best effects and best
picture boy the film really excelled
with fans and won two Oscars for was the
music picking up best original score and
best original song for over the rainbow
wait you all want to sing it along
not just me all right I'll keep it to
myself despite its critical success The
Wizard of Oz wasn't immediately
profitable but all that changed with a
lucrative re-release in theaters a
decade later that was followed by the
1956 television premiere on CBS and from
there that Medium has continued to
introduce this movie to new generations
in the decades since ultimately being
declared by the Library of Congress as
the most seen film in movie history
that's what you call a mic drop Mary
Poppins
she's answered our system Rosie cheeks
and everything
foreign
you may now show them in one at a time
yes sir
[Applause]
you may come in one at a time
next on this list is 1964's Mary poppin
this film is directed by Robert
Stevenson and produced by Walt Disney
and is based on a series of eight Mary
Poppins children's books by PL Travers
which began publishing in 1934. Julie
Andrews stars as the titular character a
magical nanny in turn of the century
London who uses her unique ways to help
a family improve its dynamic in
relationships while Mary Poppins has
become an all-time Classic Family movie
over the years it was also a family
affair from the get-go because it was
Walt Disney's daughters who were fans of
the book they made him promise to do a
movie about them that's some good
thinking girls star Andrews will become
a household name for more than one
classic family flick but this actually
marked her feature film debut she beat
out stars like Angela Lansbury and Betty
Davis who are also being considered you
see in every job that must be done there
is an element of fun
you find the fun and snap the jobs again
Mary Poppins became the highest grossing
film of 1964 and at the time of its
release was Disney's highest grossing
film ever it also received 13 Academy
Award nominations including best picture
and it won five including best actress
for Julie Andrews add all that up and
that's why this is considered the
crowning achievement in live action for
Walt Disney whereas his crowning
achievement and theme park rides has got
to be Space Mountain right yeah I'll die
on that hill and along with being a
classic the Legacy for this one includes
2013's Saving Mr Banks a biographical
drama on the making of This film and a
sequel Mary Poppins returns which came
out in 2018 with Emily Blunt as Mary
Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory
this is stomach list on that
is blocking all the chocolates well what
happens now well the pressure will get
him out terrific pressure is building up
behind the blockage
I wonder how long he's going to take him
to push through
dispense is terrible
sweetening things up next on this list
is 1971's Willy Wonka and the Chocolate
Factory the film is directed by Mel
Stewart and adapted from Roald Dahl's
1964 novel Charlie and the Chocolate
Factory it stars Gene Wilder as Willy
Wonka and tells the story of a poor
child named Charlie who after fighting a
golden ticket in a chocolate bar visits
Willy Wonka's chocolate factory along
with four other children from around the
world one big reason Willy Wonka has
landed on this list is because of the
reactions it elicits from kids and
parents alike and that was helped Along
by the fact that for instance none of
the actors were told that Willy Wonka
would go from a limp into a somersault
during his entrance at the factory Gates
catching genuine surprise on camera
here it comes blueberry pie and cream
it's the most marvelous blueberry pie
I've ever tasted holy Toledo what's
happening to your face
yeah but your face is turning blue
violet you're turning Violet Violet what
are you talking about I told you I
haven't got it quite right yet plus none
of the child actors were allowed to see
the chocolate room set until the day of
the shoot and now I'm already craving a
chocolate room and they weren't warned
about the tunnel boat ride scene
providing a good old-fashioned scary
moment for everyone involved and much
like a few films on today's list the
music also helped bring the whole family
together it was Oscar nominated for best
original score and introduced by the
song the Candyman which was recorded by
Sammy Davis Jr for the soundtrack and
became his only number one hit but
believe it or not despite all that and
premiering on TV on Thanksgiving in 1974
Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory
remained a bit of an obscurity until
repeated TV airings began in the 1980s
The Princess Bride you never said
anything about killing anyone I've hired
you to help me start a war it's a
prestigious line of work with a long and
glorious tradition
I just don't think it's right getting
into some job am I going mad or did the
word think Escape your lips you were not
hired for your brains you hippopotamic
land man walking down the aisle to this
next spot on the list is 1987's The
Princess Bride the film is directed and
co-produced by Rob Reiner and written by
William Goldman adapted from his 1973
novel the same name which has its own
loyal audience just like the movie This
fairy tale adventure is about a farm boy
turned pirate played by Gary elways
who's trying to reunite with his one
true love played by Robin Wright while
encountering various enemies and other
obstacles along the journey pulling off
this adaptation and turning it into a
full-on family classic was no easy task
which began with getting the project off
the ground before Reiner was able to
pull it off other directors attempted to
adapt the novel including Francois
truffaut Robert Redford and Norman
jewison trying to trick me into giving
away something
it has worked you've given everything
away I know where the poison is then
make your choice I will and I choose
what in the world can that be what where
I don't see anything
I sworn I saw something I thought no
matter the Princess Bride did just okay
the box office initially but through VHS
and eventually DVD rentals along with TV
airings it went on to become a cult film
that had considered one of the best of
the decade this movie won the 1988 Hugo
Award for best dramatic presentation and
picked up an Oscar nomination for yep
best original song it was Storybook Love
produced by Mark Knopfler of Dire
Straits who also composed the film's
score it always comes back to music with
the family flicks talks of a remake
popped up in 2019 and fans didn't react
well on social media Elway's later said
in their defense there's a shortage of
perfect movies in this world it would be
a Pity to damage this one
Who Framed Roger Rabbit
[Music]
I could get the refrigerator
[Music]
next up on our list of all time classic
family movies is 1988's Who Framed Roger
Rabbit this live-action animation hybrid
was directed by Robert zemeckis and
Loosely adapted from Gary K Wolf's 1981
novel who censored Roger Rabbit the film
is set in a 1947 version of Hollywood
where people coexist with cartoon
characters or tunes and it stars Bob
Hoskins as a private investigator who
tries to help exonerate Roger Rabbit a
tune who's been framed for murder one of
the biggest ways this movie helped bring
the whole family together and build its
status as a classic in the process is by
incorporating and referencing so many
classic cartoon characters and this was
achieved through the help of Steven
Spielberg who served as a producer
through his amblin entertainment Banner
he was able to convince Warner Brothers
and multiple other Studios to let their
characters be in this film resulting in
things like Donald Duck and Daffy Duck
appearing together and Mickey Mouse and
Bugs Bunny also sharing a scene I've
worked with a lot of life quackers but
you are despicable
me
this is the last time I work with
someone with a speech impediments
This Means War plus Who Framed Roger
Rabbit has been credited for bringing a
renewed interest in the Golden Age of
animation and even spearheading a bit of
an animation Renaissance the film ended
up grossing over 350 million dollars
worldwide becoming the second highest
grossing of 1988 behind rain man they
received a ton of worthy praise for its
performances writing and humor just the
right mix for kids and adults to go
along with all kinds of love for its
visuals with many fans and critics using
the term groundbreaking that was backed
up by an Academy Award for best visual
effects to go along with two more for
best film editing and best sound effects
editing plus it made everyone wish we
could be friends with a tune right I'll
take baby Herman home alone I'm up here
you morons come and get me
you guys give up or you're thirsty for
more
don't worry Marv I'll get them for you
[Music]
and not getting left behind on this list
is 1990s Home Alone the film is directed
by Chris Columbus a couple years after
making his debut with adventures in
babysitter it stars Macaulay Culkin is a
boy who has accidentally left behind
when his family heads to the airport in
a hurry leaving him to protect a big
empty house from two burglars who've
been casing the neighborhood and if you
want to know how Home Alone became an
all-time classic look no further than
writer John Hughes who also wrote
another holiday classic in National
Lampoon's Christmas Vacation the year
prior Hughes who conceived the film
while preparing for vacation and
wondered what happened if he left his
son behind suggested that they cast
Culkin after his experience with the
actor on Uncle Buck but to give the
screenplay that added layer and really
put it over the edge in appealing to all
sensibilities Chris Columbus did an
uncredited rewrite to add in the old man
Marley character and give the story a
more emotional ending a stroke of jeans
hey guys
check this out go back
Home Alone gross nearly 477 million
dollars around the world to become the
second highest grossing film of the Year
behind Ghost and the highest grossing
live-action comedy ever until the
release of The Hangover Part 2 took its
place in 2011. on top of that it
solidified Culkin as a child star
complete with a Golden Globe nomination
for best actor in a musical or comedy
plus it earned two Oscar knobs for best
original score shout out to the Maestro
John Williams and best original song for
Somewhere In My Memory but most
importantly this film is on pretty much
everyone's short list of what to watch
during the holiday season a tradition
that has proven to span multiple
generations to this day cool running see
at the finish line with the kinds of
questions you guys are capable of we
might actually see the Jamaicans win an
Olympic medal so this is it we could see
history in the making
[Music]
competing for the gold medal on this
list is 1993's Cool Runnings the film is
directed by John turtletop who's also
done movies like three ninjas and
National Treasure it's Loosely based on
the true story of the Jamaica national
bobsled team's debut in competition
during the 1988 Winter Olympics in it
four Jamaican Bob spiders who've never
even set foot in snow before enlist the
help of a disgraced former champion who
is desperate to redeem himself played by
John Candy to try and fulfill their
Olympic Dreams there's plenty of reasons
Cool Runnings has found its way onto
this list one of which being that it was
originally intended had been a serious
sports drama before it eventually
evolved into a comedy would it have
worked as a drama I mean probably but it
would have become an all-time classic
I'm not so sure the film's soundtrack
also seemed to move the needle for
people especially its inclusion of Jimmy
Cliff's cover of I Can See Clearly Now
Rich reached the top 40 as a single in
the United States and elsewhere and
helped keep the film in the ethos
[Music]
I see Power I see a badass mother who
won't take no crap off of nobody once
again I see price Junior I see Power I
see a badass mother who won't take no
proper for nobody that's right join your
baby
what are you going the cast has also
been a big reason for the long-standing
success of Cool Runnings and while guys
like Dougie Doug and Leon give memorable
performances it was a pretty special one
from John Candy but you'll also see in
Home Alone Kurt Russell and Scott Glenn
were both reportedly considered for the
role of Coach Blitzer but candy insisted
on the role and agreed to take a pay cut
to do the film it ended up marking the
final film to be released before his
death five months later the film did
perform well at the box office pulling
in nearly 155 million dollars worldwide
with Richard Harrington of the
Washington Post calling it a wholesome
engaging frequently hilarious ultimately
inspirational film Toy Story what do you
[Music]
[Music]
come on let's get out of here go back to
your live citizens coming to life next
on this list is 1995's Toy Story
directed by Jon Laster and his
directorial debut this was the first
computer animated feature film and the
first full-length offering from Pixar
Animation Studios it features the voices
of Tom Hanks Tim Allen and Don Rickles
to name a very few and takes place in a
world where toys come to life when
humans are not present now there's a few
big reasons this animated film has found
itself on a list of classic family
movies and not classic kids movies and
that starts with a script when Disney
approached Pixar about doing a feature
film both sides agreed they wanted the
tone to be edgier than what Disney was
known for in the animated space at the
time so much so the production was even
halted and the script was Rewritten at
one point
so play nice
and to add the perfect touch on top of a
great cast story and script was an
original score by Randy Newman who has
continued to lend his iconic sound to
every film of the franchise Toy Story
dominated at the box office with over
373 million dollars worldwide as one of
the top grossing films of the year it
also received Academy Award nominations
for Best original screenplay and best
original song for are you singing it to
yourself yet You've Got a Friend in Me
the latter of which would somehow lose
to Colors of the Wind from Pocahontas
and I'm only telling you this because it
seems like maybe they got that one wrong
in hindsight I don't know a Monday
Morning Quarterback this is considered
by fans and critics to be one of the
best animated films ever so it's no
surprise that a multimedia franchise was
born not long after you got your three
sequels a 3D re-release and a spin-off
film later and we're still cooking today
Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone
I am
well of course you are
I've got something for you afraid I may
have sat on it at some point but I
imagine it'll taste fine just the same
painted myself words and all
it's not every day your young man turns
11 now is it hey
bringing some Wizardry to this list next
is 2001 Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's
Stone the film is based on JK Rowling's
1997 novel the same name and marks the
first installment of the Harry Potter
film series it stars Daniel Radcliffe as
Harry Potter and follows his first year
at Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry as he discovers that he is a
famous Wizard and begins his formal
Wizarding education now part of what
makes this movie what it is in this case
an all-time Family Classic is what it
isn't meaning at one point during
development Steven Spielberg reportedly
showed interest in adapting this as an
animated film with Haley Joel Osment
providing Harry's voice there was also
talk later down the road about
incorporating elements from multiple
books into one film due to concerns over
the child actors aging too quickly but
JK Rowling denied all of the above
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
she's also the one who insisted on an
all-british cast like Rupert Grint and
Emma Watson to go along with Radcliffe
and she hand-picked Alan Rickman to play
Snape giving him details about the
character that nobody else would know
right up until the final novel in the
end the Sorcerer's Stone was a massive
hit earning nearly a billion dollars
during its initial run good enough to be
the highest grossing film of the year
and second highest grossing film ever at
that time the movie also racked up three
Academy Award nominations and was
followed by seven sequels not to mention
a full-on franchise complete with all
the possible merchandise you can think
of I'm saying this is a guy who's drank
many butter beers himself
School of Rock and there used to be a
way to Stick it to the Man it was called
rock and roll
but guess what oh no the man ruined that
too with a little thing called MTV
said I don't waste your time trying to
make anything cool or Pure or awesome
because Amanda's gonna call you a fat
washed up loser and crutch your soul so
do yourselves a favor and just give up
and the final installment on this list
of all time classic family movies is
2003's School of Rock the film is
directed by Richard linklater known for
films like Dazed and Confused and later
Boyhood and was written by Mike White
who more recently created the hit HBO
miniseries the White Lotus this one
Stars Jack Black as enthusiastic
guitarist Dewey who poses as a
substitute teacher after he's thrown out
of his bar band and turns his students
on to the rock gods he idolizes getting
them in touch with their inner rock and
roll personas and entering a local
Battle of the Bands competition one huge
reason for this film's Classic Family
status is Jack Black who's also in a
real band called Tenacious D and
everything that he brought to that role
he played much of his own guitar in the
film he worked a stage dive gone wrong
into one scene after seeing the Cults
Ian Asberry try a similar move and he
was honor with an MTV movie award for
best comedic performance for his efforts
School of Rock also introduced a handful
of young Stars including Miranda
Cosgrove and her first film role you're
the worst teacher I've ever had summer
that is great I like the delivery
because I felt your anger thank you
you're a fat loser and you have body
odor
all right
all right all right now is everyone
yeah good time to write a rock song now
what makes you mad more than anything in
the world
foreign
Billy you
Billy we've already told me off let's
move on you're tacky and I hate you but
since she can actually sing in real life
she had to take a bad singing lesson
from a scene in which she sings horribly
I mean the things that we do for our art
the film went on to gross 131 million
dollars worldwide and marked the highest
grossing music themed comedy of all time
until his dethroned finally by Pitch
Perfect 2 in 2015 and the Legacy for
this one has been impressive along with
helping to ignite a new generation of
young musicians in less traditional
settings there was also a stage musical
adaptation of the film that opened on
Broadway in December of 2015. the film
also spawned a television adaptation
that premiered on Nickelodeon on March
12 2016 and ran for three seasons well
that's it our list of all-time classic
family movies tell us which one is your
favorite and is there one that you think
we left off like The Adventures of Milo
and Otis let us know right now and
remember the good thing about a great
Classic Family movie is that even if
your family can be annoying at least
y'all got a good movie to watch thanks
for tuning in to two Essentials I'm your
host Mark Ellis and an all-time classic
family member to my parents and siblings
right Mom
[Applause]
[Music]